I took my kids to see the movie rogue
one and you in their opinion and in mind
you just kind of stole the movie you're
so funny in that movie wow thank you
very much so traffic funnier than Darth
Vader yeah
right Daria did some good lines off you
were hilarious
you are k2s oh yes yes correct name of
the droid and how did you come up with
that voice were there different attempts
to come up with different voices yes the
the director first asked me to do an
American accent which was just kind of
this accent and then he said we'll
probably go with an English accent
because he's from the empire he's been
reprogrammed and so I thought you know
fantastic let's do the our fight is a
pillock yeah he said no different
different English accent so I went with
k2so4 proper and since he was
reprogrammed he's a little more like a
boy and says things like no one likes
you
ya know what's greatest he says what's
ever on his on his mind and very dry
witty very dry and my kids were howling
the entire time every line of yours got
a huge screams from them
you